Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
moon knight king the conqueror marvel video
there's a really cool connection between kang and
what happened with the mcu guys they just teased
recently on moon knight and it goes all the way
back to the loki episodes that i did videos for
last year so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes we're doing a giveaway
for disney plus memberships all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and post all your
kang theories on the video but recently a lot
of you have been asking about the mcu timeline
changes and how moonite fits into everything and
the mcu gods that are part of the pantheon that
konchu comes from the enid because according to
the show that group of gods left the main mcu
dimension leaving their physical earthly forms
and went to another pocket dimension outside
the mcu that they're calling the overvoid the
comics called the other void but it's the same
basic place but inside that pocket dimension
the mcu guys that we're talking about that we
just saw are protected from any big changes
in the mcu timeline they're also protected from
things like the infinity stones thanos the snap
everything at avengers infinity war avengers end
game what's going on with khonshu is just a little
bit different but he is also trapped outside the
main mcu dimension too he's banished from the
presence of the other gods but he's still trapped
outside the main mcu dimension which is why he can
only appear inside marc spector's head that's
why he's the only person who's able to see him
and this is really important they set up a
bunch of really cool history during moon knight
episode one they gave you a bunch of critical mcu
history for the gods this particular group of gods
left the mcu dimension about 2000 years ago when
that happened they also trapped amen in her tomb
and khonshu rebelled against the other gods
because he didn't think that they should leave
humans to their own devices that's why they
banished him the first time but the textbooks
that stephen is reading call this event the great
rift where humankind essentially turned away from
this group of gods and stopped worshiping them
because they started worshiping other things
there were a bunch of things over the course of
a couple thousand years that contributed to the
great rift but the biggest reasons will seem very
familiar and for those of you asking about the
eternals too because they're incredibly old during
this era they were still very active they came to
earth about 7 000 years ago so that means that for
a period of about 5 000 years they coexisted with
a lot of these mcu gods on earth and even though
the moonite series has only implied this a lot
of the gods here especially the ones at the trial
are younger than the other gods mcu gods can have
biological children the same way that regular
people have children so for instance konchu is
meant to be the sister of boss the panther goddess
that black panthers people worship and get a lot
of their power from but they're meant to be the
biological children of a tum who's been referenced
in the show earlier we've seen some idols of him
who's kind of their version of ra the sun god so
atom who's supposed to be kind of the leader of
their pantheon who we haven't seen physically on
the show yet is supposed to be vastly older than
khonshu embossed so when the eternals first came
to earth konchu for instance had not been born yet
a lot of these gods are born during the rise of
egyptian culture because a lot of the gods draw
their power from the faith of their followers
and when they started to come into existence
a lot of their powers were based on the powers
that people believed that they had that's how
characters like amit can become more powerful than
some of the other gods because she will have more
followers theoretically thor for instance also a
much younger god he's only about 1500 years old
in present day so he's even younger than konchu
so a little while after the eternal show up konchu
and his younger cousins some of the other members
of their pantheon there are many of them the enya
that we see here is only kind of like their ruling
council there are many other god tier characters
amit being one of them she's not on the endian
but she's also viewed as another god then over
the next couple thousand years egyptian culture
flourishes rises up other gods are born but then
a bunch of things start happening that lead to
the great rift in them eventually leaving the
mcu the biggest reason being kang the conqueror
so bringing this back around to kang and how he's
kind of responsible for a lot of what's happening
during the loki series he who remains narrates a
lot of the backstory of different versions of kang
not just his own backstory but a lot of their
shared backstory because a lot of the things the
different versions did were very similar to other
versions the way he talks about it a version of
kang was born in the distant future of this mcu
earth based on the timeline that we're in right
now what happens is that that kang per the loki
series in between learning about the multiverse
alternate timelines and becoming a member of the
council of kangs trading technology with his other
variants to become more powerful eventually
he masters a version of time travel travels
back in time to ancient egypt ruling over their
society like you see in the comics calling himself
brahma tut so this is all big comic book easter
eggs that they got into during the loki series
that's what the great sphinx the pyramids all
that egyptian stuff during episode five was about
but when he goes back as rama tut and sets himself
up as a ruler because he has all this future tech
he seems like a god to them as you would expect
to make an x-men connection too because we're
going to be seeing more x-men in the mcu pretty
soon this all happened before apocalypse ruled
over them and went into long-term hibernation i
know a lot of you are asking now what does this
have to do with apocalypse's backstory in ancient
egypt and becoming the quote-unquote first mutant
or saying that he was the first mutant does this
have something to do with what scarlet witch is
doing with the multiverse during doctor strange
ii i'll explain that a little bit later in the
video because it's not quite as critical what
scarlet witch is doing is part of what happened
with kang and his backstory she's messing with
things and reality is changing a little bit
but you can explain everything between kang and
the old gods without having to explain apocalypse
it is funny to see that oscar isaac was apocalypse
during x-men apocalypse and he's also now moon
knight in the mcu you could think of them as being
variants of each other if you want to think about
it that way but in the very first version of the
timeline that we're talking about here before
the kang multiverse war when mcu king went back
to become brahmatut he's so powerful he tells
everyone and this is a big comic book easter egg
to worship him as a god instead of the old gods
conscious pantheon eventually he gets bored of
this winds up leaving going back to the future and
adopting the official name king the conquer then
the kang multiverse war begins he who remains uses
goliath to win but the idea is that a lot of them
did a lot of similar things in their backstories
but what happened is over the next few thousand
years up to about 2000 years ago his changes
that he had made in society start to take hold
eventually fewer and fewer people worship the old
gods and then finally they say enough is enough
with humanity we don't care about you anymore not
our problem because you won't worship us anymore
and they leave to go to their alternate dimension
during the loki series a lot of you were asking
about this because there were a lot of easter eggs
for him going back to ancient egypt and being
rama tut because the robe that he's wearing is
inspired by a bunch of immortus kang easter eggs
but also ancient egyptian easter eggs and a lot
of you noticed around his room all the different
shelves here there are a bunch of ancient egyptian
artifacts from his time going back to visit
there so essentially kang are a version of
kang depending on which time loop you're talking
about because when we're seeing the events of
the loki series we're kind of on the second time
loop but in either timeline a version of kang was
essentially responsible for causing the great rift
causing the mcu gods to leave the big reasons why
he would do something like that are pretty obvious
like he does have this towering ego but mostly
it's to sideline these super powerful beings
who could change reality on a whim so all he
would need to do is slowly just get people to not
care about them anymore so they wouldn't care and
wouldn't interfere with what he was doing then in
present day the reason why he's allowing a lot of
this to happen the reason why he allowed infinity
war avengers end game thanos the infinity gauntlet
snap to happen is because he's seen the entire
timeline and he knows that the mcu gods aren't
just going to permanently come back into the mcu
and start acting like they used to act if you
haven't read the moon knight comics essentially
it's still a status quo for konchu like konchu
will continue with marc spektor you'll still
see a version of moon knight doing everything
you would expect him to do inside the mcu the
other gods will stay inside the other void in
this pocket dimension i think the major idea with
the moon knight series is that eventually konchu
in marc spector will redeem themselves and the
other gods will slowly accept khonshu back into
their presence even though he himself won't want
to leave like he'll want to continue doing what
he's been doing so it's not like all the mcu
guys are suddenly going to say oh let's all come
back into the mcu dimension now and start messing
with stuff that's also kind of where gorr the god
butcher comes from in thor love and thunder he's
trying to kill all the gods of the mcu so the enid
would try to stay hidden in their pocket dimension
as much as possible they would be on gorr list
a version of kang would have seen all this
happening in the future of the timeline so he knew
that the mcu gods wouldn't really get involved
or interfere with what he was doing that much
also you have to remember at the end of the loki
series technically when tom hiddleston's alternate
version of loki comes back to the tva they're
in the middle of their third timeline because
when he came back he saw that another kang had won
the multiverse or was in the middle of winning it
and had taken over the tva and started enacting
his changes making his version of the timeline
supreme so when we talk about this version of kang
going back in time to become rama tut and then
slowly eventually getting the mcu gods to leave
it's just another example of this version doing
things that are very similar to the other versions
of kang if you're not a big comic book reader
too him mastering time travel then going back to
become ramatan was the very first act that he made
in mastering time travel but we'll learn a little
bit more about this new version during ant-man 3
and loki's season 2. he probably made some minor
changes that we'll see them have some fun with
over the course of the episodes but like i said
the major things like going back to ancient egypt
becoming a version of rama tut then coming back
to the future the kang multiverse war becoming the
true version of kang the conqueror will mostly be
the same what they're doing now in doctor strange
2 changing the mcu again using the multiverse is
that scarlet witch will probably mess up so badly
that she causes a reverse house of m scenario in
the multiverse in other realities spiderman no way
home style will start bleeding into the mcu and
that's why you'll start to see a lot of mutants
popping up in the future it won't be the only way
they explain big mutant characters in the mcu but
it'll be one of the biggest ways but for instance
kevin feige doesn't have to bring apocalypse into
the mcu the same way and explain him as part
of his backstory for everything to make sense
if you spotted any other big kang the conqueror
easter eggs in the moonlight episodes that i
didn't mention in the video post them in the
comments below we might get a couple more before
the series finale my full moonite episode 4
video will post next week just like normal
and congratulations rapture724 you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my new doctor strange
2 trailer video with a version of scarlet witch
versus a version of iron man and click here
for my moon knight episode 4 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!